in addition to signing the latest
coronavirus response package sent to him
by Congress the president also signed
the defense production act today and it
could invoke wartime authority over
production of certain equipment joining
us now to talk about what role the
military might eventually play
congresswoman presidential candidate and
major in the Hawaii National Guard Tulsi
Gabbard good to have you with us live
thanks Shannon great to see you okay so
you know as somebody who still deploys
and activates as a National Guardsman
what this could mean and I know that
there's a hesitancy from some people who
say listen some of the people that we
need are key in their civilian lives to
their medical professionals or like you
a lawmaker or doing other important
things um what would it mean to have
more of the National Guard mobilized
look I think that this is going on a
state-by-state as-needed basis but this
is literally the role and the function
of the National Guard to be able to step
up and to provide essential services
during times of crisis just like this my
first four years in the the ho Army
National Guard were spent serving in a
medical unit deployed to Iraq we were
there for nearly a year I served with
amazing medics and doctors piays nurses
and dentists all of whom yes they have
civilian jobs here but who are ready to
respond in a way that sometimes only the
National Guard is best equipped to do so
and in like states across the country I
know here in my home state people are
standing ready should that activation
occur myself included okay so you are a
multitasker you've been here in town in
Washington where the Senate has now
finally passed is the house packaged
with some technical corrections to it
and now we're looking at a third package
already there are concerns about the
price tag for this and some people
saying hey let's put the brakes on let's
see where we are let's get a little
perspective on this before we commit
billions trillions of future funds down
the road where are you in this whole
process is now we're talking about the
third package yeah we're talking about
people's lives here we're talking about
their health and safety and well-being
and I think if people are looking for a
perspective look at what's happening in
some of these other countries around the
world and let that be a warning to our
leaders to say hey we need to take
action
we need to take action to make sure that
we have the medical equipment that we
have the masks the testing kits the
ventilators that we have what is
necessary to ensure the health and
well-being of the people of this country
number one and number two for those who
are getting impacted those who are
getting laid off freelancers uber
drivers contractors people who are
losing their livelihoods because of this
global pandemic we need to provide this
direct aid I introduced a resolution
last week before leaving Washington
saying that we need to provide a minimum
of $1,000 a month to every adult
American tax-free in this country to cut
the red tape and bureaucracy get this
aid directly in their hands so they can
make the best decisions for themselves
and their families and I'm glad to see
president Trump Democrats and
Republicans really starting to push for
this kind of direct emergency assistance
all right a couple of other questions
for you first of all as we had
congressman Nunez on a little bit
earlier there are now two members of
Congress who have tested positive for
the virus you've all been working
together working around the clock in
very close quarters we get tested do you
have any concerns for yourself I think
that every member of Congress should get
tested I think that more people in this
country should get tested both those who
have symptoms and who are concerned
maybe those who don't have symptoms but
who have been exposed to someone who has
or who've traveled to some of these
other not only other countries but
communities in this country who are
experiencing some of these outbreaks we
we have to learn from what we've seen
has worked in South Korea for example
where they've tested hundreds of
thousands of people and therefore better
able to contain this virus and reduce
the threat and they're one of the few
countries at this time of a global
pandemic that are actually seeing their
numbers drastically decrease I think
it's important for Congress to exercise
that leadership the CDC the FDA they got
to break through the red tape get rid of
this very narrow testing criteria that's
standing in the way of larger scale
testing across this country and do
whatever it takes to be able to make
sure that these tests are available for
free easily accessible without
bureaucracy
the referrals or any of these other
things that are standing in the way of
people being able to keep themselves and
their loved ones and communities safe
okay and very quickly you're still a
part of the presidential race the
Democratic field there's growing now
very verbal push on senator Sanders to
drop out and to allow the former vice
president to simply become the nominee
at this point what are your thoughts on
that
senator Sanders would make his own
decision I'll be making an announcement
about the future of my campaign tomorrow
morning okay that's 80s we will tune in
congresswoman thank you for coming back
always good to see you